hi Samantha pardon from details and we
just saw the G function so here in Paris
and I am obsessed suit for this
collection the whole thing was based on
maple syrup as an inspiration and the
clothing was ultra sleek it's still
super sexy one of the first things
you'll notice when you look at this
collection is that there's an absence of
haulers and lapels on all the jackets
and I think the cool thing about is it
really elongated the silhouettes and
also made them ultra sleek and really
slick and I thought was just a really
new interesting way to design a jacket
you know one of the ways that i think
this mapplethorpe reference really came
to is there was a lot of photo- tents on
the shirts riccardo tisci loves a print
I love a friend you have to love a print
and this is how 2 parentheses that I
really thought it was very very cool
another interesting element in the
collection with that there was all these
expensive ated zippers which you know of
course added to the toughness the
masculinity and the sexiness of the
collection and it's something that you
know when you think about it you're like
once it was all over their coat but you
know at this show I wanted all of them
overall you know I thought it was a
really tough yet elegant collection if
you can afford it go for it because it's
a really
alright we only have a few more shows
left here in Paris so please for more
videos check out details calm and
remember you can always follow my
shenanigans on Instagram and Twitter at
details matter